today's speed round is brought to you by
verizon let's get right to it scale of 1
to 10 in today's verizon 5g speed round
chris
how likely is it with obviously 10 being
the most likely that the broncos trade
down
due to
significant interest in the ninth
overall pick i i think that's you know
pretty high on the richter scale there
where i'm gonna go like an eight with
the broncos i think it's a prime spot to
where
if one of the quarterbacks do fall that
people could trade up to look for and
also at number nine you're getting to
that spot too mike like we discussed
earlier it's like the premium elite
players are starting to dwindle off the
board so
if you want one of those top type of
players you know that's going to be the
time where teams are going to be
thinking about trading up for one of the
receivers or maybe one of the better
defensive players in the draft
george payton comes from minnesota where
gm rick spielman loves to trade down and
get more picks more picks more picks and
one of the key value items this year
that we've been talking about flipping a
2021 pick where you've had limited
scouting ability for a 2022 pick where
the scouting ability will be
dramatically enhanced we hope because
the pandemic we host
will be completely over by then scouting
combine
pro day workouts private workouts player
visits the things that other than the
pro day workouts we didn't have this
year yeah how likely is it and i'll
agree with you i'll go eight as well
i'll take your eight i'm not gonna be
contrarian just to pick a different
number i agree with you i think that
that uh there will be interest in nine
and they will be inclined to entertain
trading down and i think they will
saints trade up for virginia tech
cornerback caleb farley how likely is it
scale of one to ten
trade up is where i just don't know if i
can get behind that so i'm gonna go like
a four there
because
i i i just don't think you is as awesome
as caleb farley is
man i mean it's risky to trade up assets
to go get a guy that's had two back
surgeries and you know all of that type
of stuff
that's where i guess i get a little
scared of it i think if he fell to them
i think they would take him but trade up
i can't get behind that
yeah i agree with you if he falls great
but
there's too much risk involved to give
up future assets or other assets in this
draft when they don't have a ton of
picks anyway to jump up and get a guy
when there is that risk that that maybe
he's not going to be as good as he can
be for health reasons in the nfl i'll
i'll go even lower than four i'll say
two and a half yeah it's probably not
there yeah one to ten how likely is it
that washington trades up but not for a
quarterback uh okay
uh i don't see
i'll put this at like six
because i do think there's a possibility
where
um i'm gonna sneeze excuse me sorry i'm
trying to do it bless you thank you um
it's you know there's a lot of pollen in
the air up here i'm dealing with
allergies but i think
i could see a scenario maybe where if
there was a run on the offensive
alignment in the first round to maybe
where washington felt like they might
not get one because that's their biggest
glaring need other than maybe the
quarterback like we've talked about it's
probably getting an offense alignment i
could maybe see that being like oh gosh
you know everybody's going off the board
there's only you know we're four picks
away or five picks away and there's only
two of the guys we like left or
something like that so i'll i'm gonna
make it a five not a six a five
i'll agree with you there i'll go ahead
and make it i'll make it a a four and a
half uh so i'm not agreeing with you
even though i said i was but you know
you could trade up a couple spots yes i
mean we see that that's not out of the
question and yeah you don't get a
quarterback you're just trying to get
the guy that you want because there's a
run on the position where you have need
so you better go get the guy that you
want to get
giants or chargers trade up for tackle
penne sewell if he falls past the
bengals at five scale of one to ten how
likely is it that either of those teams
make the move to go get sewell giants or
chargers i'll give a i'll give a six to
that but i think it's more like i think
i'm gonna say the giants are low on that
i'm gonna more like sway with the
chargers maybe doing that sewell is
special he really is i think there's a
lot of people that view him as like
being really special and then others
that think okay he's just he's one of
the top three guys uh but the giants
i i guess where i just look at that and
go
you know they they do they drafted a
tackle in the top six last year they
have nate sold their coming back you
know they drafted a will hernandez in
the second round a few years ago so i i
guess i just don't envision them trading
up that so the chargers are the ones i'd
maybe have my eye on in that situation
and you know i asked penney sewell
earlier this week about playing for the
chargers because justin herbert
really wants to reunite with him and la
would be a lot closer to american samoa
than
detroit or atlanta or cincinnati he said
that's fine but not at 13. he he knows
how this works you want to be drafted as
high as you possibly can be drafted and
he said one of the reasons is he just
wants the stress to be over so the
chargers would have to trade up he's not
going to be there at 13. he's not going
to be there at 11. he won't be there
when the top ten end all right how light
and so i'll go i'll i'll say
if he gets past the bengals
i'll call it i'll call it a a sixth the
chargers do it and it and a one and a
half that the giants do it so i think
we're on the same page there eagles
trading up for alabama receiver jalen
waddle scale of one to ten how likely
i'm gonna go three here i just don't see
the likelihood of that if jaylen waddle
falls to them at 12 yeah i definitely
could see them making that type of pick
there's no doubt but for a team that
truly is like a rebuild right now you're
you're you're retooling the the whole
franchise
that to me trading up for the wide
receiver in a draft again that's got a
lot of good wide receivers doesn't make
a ton of sense for the eagles situation
yeah on our mark draft we have jaylen
waddle actually landing with the eagles
at
number 12 back back-to-back alabama
receivers devonta smith 11 to the giants
jalen waddle 12 to the eagles 1 to 10
how likely is it that
south carolina cornerback j.c horn son
of former nfl receiver joe horn is
drafted before alabama corner patrick
certain the second
son of former dolphins cornerback
patrick certain the first yeah some uh
sons of legends here i think i'm going
to go with um a real low number of where
it's like i'm gonna say one i am i mean
i think patrick
certain for most people is looked at as
the number one corner in the draft he
you know of course has played at alabama
had that coaching
and of course was phenomenal this past
year so you have more evidence of him
playing and doing that stuff than jc
horn who you know uh opted out after a a
game or two um so i'm gonna say one
there
last and i'll i'll say uh
i'll say two
just because i don't i don't feel like
agreeing with you but it's very low very
low packers drafting receiver rashad
bateman opted out this year from the
university of
minnesota scale of one to ten do the
packers make aaron rodgers happy this
year after
spending none draft picks would none be
accurate none draft picks on receivers
last year well i i'll think there's a
chance like
for the wide receiver position
okay like i want to say all right i'll
give that like an eight that there's a
chance they go wide receiver rashad
bateman you know do i want to pin that
name to him no i think i would go a
little lower than that you know i like
rashad bateman to me he is not a first
round talent i'd be disappointed as an
aaron rodgers fans going wait they took
him and not kedarius tony or terrace
marshall jr from lsu or the big play
threat dearmi brown from north carolina
like i would think there's going to be
some better players on the board
than bateman so that's where bayman's a
weird one you know he's there's a love
there's a love hate i think there with
him because if you watch his film from
two years ago it's way more impressive
than what you see from last year and
that's the the dividing line or the the
thing that's kind of gets argued a lot
with that player in this draft
yeah you know look i agree with you as
well the packers need receivers and and
i
i just wonder
how much of what happens over the next
three days
will be a manifestation of the current
dysfunction between team and quarterback
yeah and will they shy away from
receiver
just to just to twist it a little bit
more that very subtle but palpable
tension between organization and
franchise quarterback that that part of
it will be fun to see how it plays out
let's take a break when we return we're
gonna have a very broad and open-ended
draft of the things we want to see
happen
tonight as the draft the non-virtual
draft is back we'll be back with more
pfd live right after this
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon built right for business
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports